hallo wir sind heute in der
hellbergschule in use münde dänemark wir
beschreiben euch heute präpositionen mit
dativ und akkusativ im deutschen können
alle positionen die einen ort
beschreiben mit dativ und akkusativ
gebildet werden
der unterschied besteht darin ob man
einen ort beschreibt oder eine bewegung
beschreibt wir zeigen euch das jetzt mal
der stift liegt auf den tisch legt den
stift auf den tisch die schüler gehen in
den bus die schüler sitzen in dem bus
die schüler schieben das auto der
lehrerin auf den parkplatz
das auto steht jetzt auf dem platz wo
hin setzt sich kaminer camilla setzt
sich auf die treppe wo sitzt camilla
kamera sitzt auf der treppe das macbook
liegt auf dem tisch liegt das macbook
auf den tisch mir schießt den ball auf
das tor der ball liegt jetzt in dem tor
lukas setzt sich auf die bank lukas ist
jetzt auf der bank lucas legt den
basketball auf den tisch der basketball
liegt jetzt auf dem tisch
die schüler laufen von der bahn auf den
rasen
wohin laufen die schüler auf den rasen
die schüler laufen auf dem rasen
so laufen die schüler auf dem rasen
mir liegt das holzstück in die tasche
wohin legt sie das stück in die tasche
wo ist das holzstück jetzt das holzstück
liegt jetzt in der tasche
das handy liegt auf dem tisch
ich lege das handy auf den tisch
wir stellen uns unter das dach von wem
haus jetzt stehen wir unter dem dach von
dem haus wir gehen jetzt in die
sporthalle
wir stehen jetzt in der sporthalle
system jetzt in der sporthalle
[Musik]
[Applaus]